if you don't know I've got a the name of
the person the city in about four words
as to what they're going to talk about
on my screen before I bring them up so
you know buy my dad a car that's what it
says or something like that on the
screen it doesn't you know it's not I
don't have a lot of information more
than you guys have as listeners and so
you and I explore this information
together really when I bring a caller up
but when I saw that how to survive or
what to do to prepare for a recession I
kind of got in my mind I didn't that
didn't where he wanted to go so I was
helping him but philosophical for a
second I'm thinking okay cuz the last
time we had like a big crash in the u.s.
I made so much money that was ridiculous
I was actually going over the PLS this
morning with my son-in-law who runs our
real estate and we were just looking at
that stuff going
we bought this stuff at fifteen or
twenty cents on the dollar millions of
millions of dollars or the stuff for
fifteen or twenty cents on the dollar so
when I see how to prepare for a
recession I think be debt-free being a
strong cash possession and then when
there's a recession it's time to make
hay because it's a great time to make
money it's a great time to make money
when things are down and it's when you
buy you buy everything with bi-lo is so
high right I mean this is the plan and
so yeah if and that experience that we
went through in the in the states anyway
in Oh 8 when the world was coming to an
end and people were too big to fail and
all this stuff and you know household
names were closing down permanently in
the banking world and none of us really
cried much about that except people that
work there and but other than that we're
all just like moms yeah too big to fail
my but you failed and so but then some
of them were too big to fail and the
government bailed them out and all that
stuff is going on right there's this
huge problem everybody's freaking out
lost all my retirement no you really
didn't because the Dow was at 14,000 and
it went to 6,500 you you lost half your
retirement
if you cashed it out at the lowest
possible point which would make you the
world's biggest loser in terms of
picking times to pay cash stuff out so
if you cash it out at the very bottom
the absolute valley the apex of the
valley I mean the convicts of the valley
the very bottom of the thing you cashed
out at 6500 I didn't cash out at 6500
you know what I did
oh by the way what's the Dow right now
24,000 what's that 4x 4x put in the
million dollars a 6500 right now it's
worth four you put in 10 million right
now it's worth 40 that's what you do to
prepare for a recession you get ready
and when it dips like that you're not
sitting around wringing your hands when
you lose everything it's down half and
no one gets hurt on a roller coaster
except those that jump off that's when
you buy and I bought like crazy about
real estate more than I did even stocks
I didn't really change my stock
investing I just kept investing steadily
but boy what if you to put in 10 million
dollars
at the bottom right now today that 10
mean and be worth 40 or whatever zero or
decimal you want to put on the game it's
a 4x right so you don't lose all your
money unless you've jumped out at the
exact wrong time you didn't lose all
your money you lose any money somebody
asked Warren Buffett you said you know
you you lost you know some billion
dollars today and he's like not it and I
didn't sell anything you know you know
there's no losses until you sell
something so the way you get ready for
recession is you get out of that you
have an emergency fund the way you get
ready for government shutdown is you get
out of debt you have an emergency fund
and then you have other money to buy
stuff when times are troubled because
more millionaires are made during the
Great Depression than any other time
something to think about